hello and welcome to Beth Rigby
interviews this week I'm in conversation
with the shadow foreign secretary David
Lammy the big question what would labor
do on the world stage if it were to win
power
[Music]
in David lammy's eyes Britain's
reputation is in need of repair he says
brexit and the mishandling of Britain's
departure from the EU has left the UK
isolated I'll ask how labor plans to
reconnect
lamy's also been critical of cuts to
foreign aid so could we see a return to
spending 0.7 percent of GDP on Aid and
should the West be worried after this
recent show of solidarity between Russia
and China
we'll also discuss lamy's personal and
political Journey campaigning on issues
like the Windrush Scandal this
government holds in such disrespect the
contribution of West Indian Caribbean
and black people in this country when
when will black lives matter once again
that message had personal significance
because both lamy's parents traveled to
Britain as part of the Windrush
generation
afterwards his family's story was one of
struggle lamy's father walked out when
he was still a child leaving his mother
to bring up her children with little
money despite that Lamy defied
expectations winning a scholarship to
study at one of America's most
prestigious universities he returned to
Britain and moved into politics becoming
the youngest MP in the House of Commons
so how did he do it we caught up where
his story began back at his old Primary
School in his Tottenham constituency
David Larry thanks for joining us on the
show we've got lots to talk about but
we're actually here in your old school
in Tottenham in North London it was the
early 80s when you came here and sat at
these desperately in the library but
these were your classes when you were 9
and 10 years old what expectations did
you have back when you were a little boy
oh look I think I was in this when it
was a classroom it would have been in
about 19
seventy nine
that's a different age
and I think in those days you know
Tottenham was a
um we didn't travel much Beyond
Tottenham it was a community of the
Irish white working class Cockney
families West Indian families
um and you know if anyone would have
told me that I would be here
with you now giving an interview like
this it would have been like sort of
saying I was going to go to the Moon it
wouldn't have made sense to be honest it
was a long long not just time ago but
the distance traveled was immense
because you actually had quite a
difficult start didn't you in the sense
that your dad left when you were you've
got three siblings right well it was
look my family was a typical you know
West Indian immigrant family
in a in what felt like one of the homes
of the black community Tottenham at that
time but the truth is you know my
parents marriage was not the best
um the early 1980s particularly got very
difficult economic please certainly
difficult for my dad he started drinking
and I never saw him after the age of 12.
he left and he went to the states never
saw him again so look I don't want to
give the impression it was it was all
easy it was far from Easy
but I do feel warm about this school
about the wonderful teachers that were
here with a with an incredible sense of
mission they were determined to pick me
up by the Scruff of the neck and get me
to work and to make something in my life
I mean you must be one of their most
famous alumni I'm assuming from this
school your mum as well
um I mean she cared about education I
read somewhere that if you've got a C
which I think is actually perfectly fine
just put metal record for my own
children yeah but if you've got to see
that was a grade she did not recognize
so you were pushed yes she had been a
kindergarten teacher back in the
Caribbean she I think you know my mum
was ambitious she had a brain but for
whatever reason poverty
she was never pushed to really Excel so
she did push her kids she wanted the
best for us and look this was also a
Time difficult time there were riots in
Tottenham and there were issues with
policing you know we're talking about
that now with the Casey review but a lot
of these issues have been around for a
long time and she was absolutely clear
you are not ending up in trouble with
the police you're taking your education
you're moving forward I had a I was
blessed with a wonderful wonderful
mother you you
um and you lost your mum your mum died
from ovarian cancer so she did die from
ovarian cancer
um how old were you well it was back in
2008 okay so she's seen terribly but she
had seen you become seen me become a
member of parliament I won the contest
to be the MP for Tottenham actually just
next door in the secondary school so
this this neighborhood of Tottenham I'm
in is very much my home and you know I'm
glad that she saw that happen you talk
about it feels like you've landed on the
moon doing what you do now but it was a
meteorite rise in that you got a
scholarship to a board in school you
then went on to become the first black
Britain to graduate from Harvard
uh 27 you became an MP you'll now the
shadow foreign secretary it's quite
astonishing I mean what was in you that
drove you in that way or did it feel
like that at the time it always feels a
bit you know when people look back
because the truth is
I only applied to Harvard because there
was a wonderful show on TV called La law
and there was a wonderful black guy in
it called Jonathan Rawlins and I wanted
to be him right okay it's just random
stuff
and then the dots connect and you end up
where you where you are and just in
terms of that in terms of talking about
Role Models there's a black Britain
what's your response to Hamza Yusuf
being elected Scotland's first Minister
we have a UK prime minister a mayor of
London the Scottish first Minister all
britons from ethnic minorities but all
of those men also from a British Asian
background do you think it's harder for
black britons to scale those political
Heights I mean what's your
interpretation of that look I think that
this country
had a huge
Imperial story my parents came to this
country what they called the mother
countries part of the windrust by virtue
of that story to help rebuild this story
this country after the second world war
and that that tale is mirrored in Sadiq
Khan's story Rishi sunak story and now
Hamza use their story and in a sense I
think it's a tribute to Britain that we
now have these Multicultural emerging
political leaders that story will
continue to be written just as we have
female leaders and there will be more
female leaders and more minority leaders
we never know when but that story will
be continued to be written I'm quite
sure about that is it sometimes quite
lonely though being
kind of uh
a role model in your sphere when there
aren't that many
black men
politicians male black politicians I
mean you're you it's unusual isn't it
and it must feel odd sometimes why is it
I was never Anonymous in the Palace of
Westminster when I arrived I just stood
out like a sore thumb I was a junior
Minister I'd walk into a big government
department and use literally other than
you and the security guys that I was the
only black man in the building of
thousands of people so yeah sometimes
the burden of being the first one the
burden of leadership does feel like that
um but look that's the same in any
European country
um in a sense if you're a minority
um and so you you know you kind of have
to you have to get used to it now let's
get on to what you want to do next which
is to become Britain's Next foreign
secretary it was Shadow foreign
now it's the 20th anniversary of the
Iraq War coming up a war you supported
and it's reminding people of how
horribly wrong labor got that
um do you see that decision to invade
Iraq as a stain on Labor's history
look I think it's a good question of
course I remember I think I'd only been
in Parliament just over two years
in my own constituency here in Tottenham
the largest kurdish-speaking population
in the country many Kurds who supported
that war
many people who supported the idea of
getting rid of Saddam Hussein
now I think there were two things that
went fundamentally wrong one there were
no weapons of mass destruction and two
the preparedness once you'd won the
battle to actually reconstruct a country
was phenomenally poor
um and so like many people if I knew
then what I knew now I would never have
gone with it when I was up in Pendle
yesterday and I was talking to some
veterans they've traditionally voted
conservative and they raised they raised
it I didn't raise it but they when I
asked them about a possible future labor
government they raised the Iraq War and
said Blair had never apologized
something they were still angry about
that decision do you think it would help
if Blair apologized oh look I think in
the when I think about things that have
gone badly wrong I think that the Sue is
Crisis was a low moment I think
appeasement prior to the second world
war was a low movement moment I think
the decision that Margaret Thatcher was
making on apartheid and on not being
supportive of Nelson Mandela was a low
moment in our history
um uh that's the nature of History uh
there are high moments and low moments
and there's always the benefit of
hindsight let's go to the dominant
foreign policy issue you will face if
you become foreign secretary which is of
course the war in Ukraine essentially it
seems that you're in the same place as
the conservative government is there
something you do differently such as
offering more Military Support or
providing fighter jets
Beth I am really anxious to say that the
war in Ukraine
a fight against the tyranny of
imperialism and a man's desire Vladimir
Putin to ransack a country take it over
and erase its own sovereignty is
existential it's not a party political
issue yeah and I'm not prepared to make
party political points out of it there
it's not conservative or labor it's
fighting on the side of people who are
fighting for their freedom a freedom
that we enjoy in this country and that
we hold their dear so of course the
labor party in kirst armor reiterated
this when he met zelenski we're there
with you politically economically
militarily and diplomatically okay let's
go to another foreign policy area that
is is important to all Western allies
and that's China in recent days you've
been talking quite tough on China you've
said in government you would seek to
have China's persecution of the uighur
Muslims internationally recognized as a
genocide how would you go about that
that's something you have to do
multilaterally but we're clear that the
Biden Administration has described it in
that way
um the UN special commissioner has
described it in that way and our
Parliament here in the UK voted in a
motion uh it's a legal definition
um and so that has to be done
um through the auspices of the UN and
with others but what would be bayesian's
reaction
to that well beijing's reaction would of
course be I suspect to resist that
um and we know that one of the issues at
the moment with the United Nations and
the Security Council is that Russia and
China continue to use their veto as a
block we've not used ours since 1989 and
so it is extremely difficult the reason
I ask
um you this is because you say in your
um your big blueprint for foreign policy
which which we will come on to in a bit
you say you will compete Challenge and
where you can cooperate with China but
how could that possibly happen if you
took that course I've been very clear
that there are issues like climate
change where we will cooperate and seek
to cooperate with China
indeed we have a 93 billion trading
relationship with China as does the
United States my point is just as the
United States have recently challenged
China you know they've drafted this
legislation to ensure that China
um that they're dealing with the issues
of semiconductors they're dealing with
issues of the Renewables that China is
much dominant in the supply chain at the
moment the United States acting to do
with that we have to do the same just to
be clear then you would make that a
labor policy into the next general
election we will work multilaterally
with others it goes in your
manifestation right breaches it goes in
your Manifesto oh I'm not going to
determine the bits of what I said that
go in the manifesto because that's a
that's a Scramble with lots of other
colleagues but the point is we will
always stand up for human rights on your
foreign policy approach Britain
reconnected about
connecting back and plug in the UK back
more into the world there's a theme that
runs through that policy statement which
is the danger of British disconnection
from the world what's the most
significant example of Britain doing
that in recent years tearing up our
leadership on the rule of law
saying to the Americans we don't care
saying to the Europeans we don't care
and despite signing an agreement with
you we're going to introduce a bill
called the Northern Ireland protocol
bill that tears up our relationship
um I think describing president macron
as an enemy I think in the government's
integrated review not anticipating the
Taliban coming back in Afghanistan and
The Botch withdrawal with a foreign
secretary lying on the beach in Crete
when he should have been attending to
those issues I think the dismantling of
our leadership role in International
Development all of this has been
basically Britain preoccupied not in the
into in the international game stepping
back from our usual position at a very
very dangerous time indeed you said it's
self-evident since today was that no
country computes interest or secure its
objectives were low in a world
increasingly shaped by geopolitical
competition Regional blocks of power and
trade we can't build our strength by
going it alone so I thought your answer
would be brexit but it wasn't
that theme that was used during brexit
Take Back Control
I want to concede
that it was being used at a high point
if you like in globalization that was
affecting many people's lives
particularly
in former industrial Britain and that it
was correct but what was wrong about the
way that many conservatives saw that
phrase Take Back Control was that they
thought it was about Britain isolated in
the world in which we could go It Alone
and my message is really clear
Putin's behavior in Russia
China's assertion in the Taiwan Seas and
its determination to change the world
order in its in its order in its favor
the behavior of Iran in our own country
by the way not just in their in that
country the problems we're seeing in the
Middle East all of this demonstrates
that we cannot go it alone so presumably
you wish brexit hadn't happened
brexit has happened but let us be clear
the execution of brexit is down to Boris
Johnson Liz tracks others they've left
us badly isolated with trade falling
badly with our Europeans and our
partners with growth down with a cost of
living crisis and with very little
indication of of how we will get growth
back into it well that wasn't and I we
will come on to that and how you might
as a labor party wish to do brexit
better but my my question to you was do
you wish it hadn't happened not I wasn't
asking about how it was executed do you
wish that we had not left the European
Union I'm a realist
growing up
in Tottenham in the 1970s and 80s with
the life that I've had has left me a
realist it did happen it has happened I
was on one side of that debate I thought
at the time that we should remain but we
have left the European Union
um and so it's now about making the very
very best of the opportunities that we
have your policy statement makes it very
clear that you believe isolation is a
disaster for Britain it's not the right
way to go particularly from Europe but
at the same time you won't openly
repudiate brexit and I find that curious
policy wise it doesn't make sense
because it goes against what you want
it makes complete sense
the first thing we need to do is
normalize our relations with Europe at
the moment we've not even got a
structured dialogue with Europe under
this government so let's normalize our
relationship with Europe we then need to
build on the relationship that we've got
and then and your document you say the
problem wasn't brexit but the way it was
handled are you now then David lamia
born again brexiteer
[Laughter]
look I'm what's in the interests of
British people I would say let us put an
end to the ideology and the fanaticism
of groups like The ERG okay Britain at
its best has always been a pragmatic
Nation you do what's in the interests of
the British people and at the moment in
the in the geopolitical world with China
and Russia Rising we need to be close to
our allies in Europe both
um economically of course but certainly
politically and diplomatically but David
I mean people will be watching this and
they would have heard you say I'm
pragmatic we have to sorts in the
interests of British people
but the labor party seemed to completely
back a government approach to hard
brexit because you say that Labor's plan
to reconnect with you at Romanian
outside of the EU the single market and
the Customs Union you could have forged
a different approach more in line with
Norway or Switzerland you could have
tried to rejoin a customs Union you
explicitly rule all of this out despite
the obr saying that there will be in the
long term of four percent hit to the
economy over the size of Econo the next
10 years why is that in the interest of
the British people it it's contradictory
I mean Beth in a sense you're going back
several years I'm not I'm saying to you
I I I'm saying Beth that you are
pursuing a hard brexit approach but as
the labor party you could have said we
want to go back into the Customs Union
but you won't Why Beth brexit has
happened we are outside of the European
Union and you and I as adults know
that when you get divorced and it's
messy the idea that in a few weeks time
you can get remarried again when you
haven't even been on a first date it's
pretty unrealistic or indeed sorted out
how you're going to take care of the
children so we have left the European
Union just one other thing on this as of
March 2023 53 percent of people in Great
Britain thought it was wrong to leave
the European Union compared with 33 who
thought it was right right during the
same period people who regret brexit
have been higher than those who
supported so there is potential
conversation to be had in this country
and isn't the truth of this and it's
okay if this is what it is but isn't the
truth that you and kirstma Aren't having
this conversation because you're scared
it will be used by the conservatives to
attack you in a general election Beth
let me look you in the eyes and be
crystal clear
I've been to Brussels
on a few occasions since I've took this
job the first thing that they say to you
is if if you if you were to mention
going back and is there consensus in the
United Kingdom
and the truth of that
is that there is not consensus because
we have one political party that I'm
afraid would not sign up to that
so let us not go back over the horses
the definition of Madness is doing the
same thing over and over again and
expecting a different outcome and now
this is a question for David Lammy the
pastor not the politician would you
personally like to see reconsidered at
some time in the future are uh
relationship our membership of the
European Union are you a born-again
brexitier for life
but I'm I'm a pragmatic politician the
conservative government as you said
earlier have cut the development Target
from 0.7 to 0.5 it's also emerged today
from the Independent commission for Aid
impact that a third of the foreign
offices Aid pot is currently being spent
by the home office on domestic support
for refugees and Asylum secrets in the
UK number one do you support the use of
the Oda budget to sort out issues and
fund issues around
um domestic problems around refugees and
Asylum Seekers do you support that
policy to have got to a position where
we've cut our a budget
um from 0.7 to 0.5 and then we're
spending 3.5 billion pounds of taxpayers
money on hotels is a scandal
uh it's a scandal that means that we're
doing nothing or very little to deal
with those girls education malaria TB
HIV and many of those issues that drive
people moving from their countries into
Europe and and trying to gain
access to our own country all of that's
been abandoned
um and I'm absolutely clear that we
would not be spending the a budget in
this way that we are committed as soon
as the fiscal environment allows to get
back to 0.7 and our Global Leadership in
the space that's International
Development I was going to ask you that
because you talk about it um being an a
pledge you talk about it being a
strategic imperative but you do stop
short of actually formally committing to
return to the 0.7 so are you here and
now commit that a future labor
government will do that we will return
to to 0.7 the issue is about how quickly
we can do that in the fiscal economic
environment I wish I could tell you Beth
that we'll do it next year or we'll do
it in the first first year in office I
can't tell you that because I don't know
what were you doing I don't know what
economics I don't know what the
economics is will you do in the next
Parliament if you are in government if I
say to you now
that I will do it in the next next
Parliament I will be making judgments
about our economy that I cannot make and
by the way Rachel Reese will be on the
phone so I can't give you that promise
okay so what so you're going to get
Rachel Reese put it in the manifesto is
that your job we're absolutely clear we
will get back to 0.7 as soon as the
fiscal climate allows we've seen this
week Matt Hancock and quasi quite
embarrassed by The Sting operation about
well-paid second jobs and it it's
allowed in the rules you you've
benefited from having second jobs as
well earning over 240 000 pounds since
2019 outside of your role as Shadow for
a section mp uh much of it can be seen
as political work of assault like your
work at LBC but other work giving
speeches to many people it does feel
wrong were you embarrassed or
uncomfortable when that story came out I
think there's a debate in our country
about second jobs I think there's debate
boiled down to two issues by the way
they boil down to lobbying and a real
concern that members of parliament are
not using their status to lobby for
special interests who otherwise would
not get a look in one and two of course
quite rightly they're also concerned
about the hours and the time that MPS
are putting into other work
um Parliament I think the labor party is
right to say that we need to fix this
problem it will be one of those issues
that parliament's going to have to
determine has it made you think twice
about what you're doing I I personally
don't think that presenting on LBC on a
Sunday morning when I should be at
church or indeed doing after dinner
speeches and by the way Beth I don't get
paid what Theresa May gets paid for I
know but I don't think no one's
complaining about those hours no one is
suggesting that I'm in the pocket of LBC
or anybody else but I do think there's
an issue and and look and if Parliament
determines that no second jobs at all we
can't have people who are the doctors we
can't have people who are lawyers one
job only being an MP then I will have to
live with that like everybody else
yeah I know it's just so I mean some I
know you do obviously but some of your
things such as speaking at JP Morgan you
gave a speech at Facebook for three
thousand pounds some people might look
at that and think what's he doing he's
meant to be an MP why is he why is he
doing that does it make you think oh
maybe actually this doesn't pass the
sniff test uh there are look the truth
is when you're in opposition and you
wanted to do a job as you know like
being Shadow foreign secretary and your
party's just lost an election there is
no money in the coffers you do try and
raise money to help employ people so you
can possible so you don't Pockets it for
yourself personally it goes into your
office some of that money goes towards
paying for the things so I can do my job
as best as I can those are the sorts of
decisions that you make as I've said
MPS have done speeches and things
um corporate speeches after dispatches
for years and years and years and years
there are lots of conservative
colleagues doing it there are other
labor MPS that have done it if people
determine that they don't want to see
that then that will come to an end and
it won't happen okay just finally are
you happy to see Jerry Corbin fellow
North London labor MP for many years be
banned from standing again as a labor MP
this is a determination that the NEC
have made they've made the determination
for all the reasons that your viewers
will know and it's Jeremy's refusal
really to apologize he's your friend
isn't he
it's not about friendship you know these
are bigger issues I represent in
representing Tottenham I represent
partly the Stamford Hill area of London
which has a very strong long-standing
Jewish community so the issue goes to
that one and
um no one ever said that politics
sometimes hasn't got to be brutal it was
an important decision I think for both
kirstarma to take when he took over the
labor party to be absolutely clear that
we would get rid of that anti-Semitism
and for the NEC to take so you think
it's the right decision I think it was
okay all right David Lamy thank you so
much for your time it's an absolute
pleasure to talk to you thank you thank
you
David Lammy there on a wide range of
subjects I hope you enjoyed that
conversation and if you scan the QR code
on screen right now you can listen to
the Beth Rigby interviews podcast each
week I take a look at the highlights of
my interviews and there are some extra
bits and pieces in there too about the
political week that'll be on the Sky
News app or wherever you get your
podcasts well that's all for today's
show thank you so much to my guest David
Lammy and thank you for watching
foreign